[Music]  Lincoln motors premiered a new car  commercial this past weekend during the  first NFL game  I don't you saw this it featured Matthew  McConaughey  now clearly Lincoln the Glink and car  companies trying to take advantage of  McConaughey status now is a serious  actor but I don't know if he's the right  fit for this car commercial well I'll  show it to you take a look I've been  driving a Lincoln since long before  anybody paid me to drive on didn't do it  to make a statement I just liked it  people out here they don't even know the  outside world exists  [Applause]  so  one ghetto man giant gutter in outer  space  I think human consciousness was a tragic  misstep in evolution we became too  self-aware the honorable thing for our  species to do is stop reproducing and  and into extinction one last midnight  brothers and sisters opting out of a raw  deal  [Applause]  [Music]  you